why-why-why the only thing that makes
sense no you can shoot from where I'm
standing we are going on an adventure
today you know I live in Los Angeles but
I'd never explored downtown I just I
just haven't done it like most people I
live in a town and I don't explore
anything but today I'm changing that I'm
gonna use Google search to find a new
place to eat a new place to drink and
something new to do all nearby where I
currently am I don't even know where I
am so I'm gonna have to use Google to
figure it out but I'm not gonna do it
alone I got to find a stranger first
it'd be so sad if I did this alone there
so I'm gonna go chase these people let's
see if this works out hi how's it going
you got any fun plans for today they're
together
no cool dogs look out oh my God look how
fluffy targets that's amazing how you
doing you're walking with a mug of
coffee
that's incredible jealous of your coffee
situation no I'm good thank you though
thank you miss them hide your day going
do you have any plans for the day oh
really
oh nice I've never visited downtown so I
was trying to find somebody who wanted
to experience downtown with me you use
Google ever yeah of course you're a
person I forgot your name already all
right yeah well it's not not Eric it's
Andrew well I tried it's like a little
after 9:00 you like breakfast
do you like brunch it's not too familiar
with brunch but I do like no no no I'm
not familiar brunch that's too bright
brunch let me do brunch nearby the first
one that looks like it's right next to
us it's edible you've been there no me
neither
great Andrew and Keith will hang out
Joey eat much of bowl food before I've
had food that's been in a bowl you have
like cereal probably yeah we're gonna
try to pick something that we've
actually never eaten a whole new
experience I mean I love chicken I
always have chicken waffles but I
haven't had honey lemon chicken with
pecans
I'm sure Sears Andrew thank you for
brunch yeah for sure yeah yes I have a
weird reaction to fried chicken where it
actually makes me happy
[Music]
you don't think I'm sheltered but I have
never had chicken and waffles
Andrew what's wrong with you mouth
Andrew five chickens legit those move
with joy do you know of anything even to
do in downtown me can we ask Google what
to do yeah oh there's a staple sentence
that's what people do they do sports try
to go to a Lakers game I will go further
down this rabbit hole right will it's
not to the community so you have to hang
out with me for eight hours all right I
mean that's good though but 6:30 gives
us plenty of time to find lots of places
to drink yeah what kind of booze do you
like whiskey and coke I'm an
old-fashioned kind of guy I think old
fashions okay let's do frisky bar top
search seven grand just about a mile
away from here it says stylish watering
hole with hunting lodge decor I thought
it said hunting lodge for old-school
cocktails at a massive whisky collection
let's go all right so we're on our way
to seven grand right there dad's got the
stash seven grand
oh wow they do have a lot of whiskey and
a lot of animal heads too so Viktor tell
me tell me about this bar what is this
bar huh we have over 800 whiskeys what
would you recommend whiskey sour
I'm gonna try this old-fashioned let's
do that why whiskey cause it's delicious
yeah
[Music]
thank you very much hmm oh good what do
you want the most out of life when I
want to bring educational program back
to television like Bill Nye disaster I
would use my talents to teach at one
point get there yeah you tain education
entertainment Andrew the mathematician
Andrews incredible biology lesson it's
not a very catchy title but we'll work
on that here's to a good son yeah well
we're actually gonna see a Lakers game
this evening and I don't remember who
they're playing hell they like your
schedule on the plane the suns these are
fun names yeah you know basketballs got
some fun names it's a classy
establishment maybe we should play like
fantasy pool I like mine ball I don't
know how to play them yeah I like the
one ball and hits the nine ball and you
win the game it's over you keep yelling
no no you go I go to Google and yes so
the Google said now you have to aim for
the one ball and you won the game what
do you do if you knock a nine ball you
won I did I'm not kidding you hit the
one ball into the nine ball that's the
kv-1 the game you want to play too
he's gonna be on my team against you oh
yeah
[Music]
i'm keith by the way I assume that's Jim
nice to meet to you
Hey here comes Keith ah close you know
that was really close oh man it's okay
you didn't hit anything in it's okay
are you from around here I'm from Boston
up to about six weeks ago oh shoot
you just got here you just got here we
just met today we went to a place to get
breakfast we went to play self-edit Bowl
and then we're gonna go to a Lakers game
oh that's yeah that's really what you
want you want to go basketball game we
did it we're here we're at the Staples
Center
yeah we're what a day we had serious
found that new place to eat a new place
to get some drinks I made new friends
and now we're gonna go see the Lakers
I'm excited it's gonna be great but you
can't come campus can't go in the
Staples Center it's crazy illegal you
got to stay out here just imagine how
much fun we're having
oh wow look at the basketball oh my god
they scored a three-point score slam
dunk